all right we're on problem number seven
and when I copied and pasted it I made a
little bit smaller so I'm going to read
it for you just in case this is too
small for you to read but says use the
proof to answer the question below so
they gave us that angle to is congruent
to angle three so angle two or the
measure of angle two is equal to the
measure of angle three I'm starting to
get the knack of the language that they
use in geometry class which I will admit
that language kind of sends to disappear
as you leave your geometry class but
since we're in geometry class we'll use
that language so the angle angle 2 is
congruent to angle 3 which means that
they're measure is the same or that they
kind of did the same to angle
essentially fair enough
so let's see statement 1 angle 2 is
congruent to angle 3 that's given I drew
that already up here statement 2 angle 1
is congruent to angle 2 angle 3 is
congruent to angle 4 so they're saying
that angle 2 is congruent to angle 1 or
angle 1 is congruent angle 2 that's
there right there and that angle 4 is
congruent to angle 3 fair enough and
they say what's the reason that you
could give and I don't know what what I
forgot the actual terminology but I in
my head I was thinking oh opposite
angles are equal or the measures are
equal or they're congruent right and you
could just imagine two sticks and change
the angles of the intersection you'll
see that opposite angles are always
going to be congruent but let's see that
is the reason I would give opposite
angles are congruent let's see which
which statement of the choices is most
is most like what I just said
complements of congruent angles are
congruent complements supplement
vertical angles are congruent I think
that's what they call opposite angles
vertical angles I think that's what they
mean by opposite angles let me
supplements of congruent angles are
congruent that's not true corresponding
angles are congruent these are
corresponding I think this is what they
mean by vertical angles complements of
congruent angles are congruent you know
what I'm going to look this up with you
on Wikipedia
let me see vertical angles as you can
see at the age of 32 some of the
terminology starts to escape
what matters is that you understand the
intuition and then you can do these
Wikipedia search to just make sure that
you remember the right terminology let's
see what Wikipedia has to say about it
vertical angles a pair of angles is said
to be vertical or opposite oh I guess I
use the British English opposite angles
if the angle share the same vertex and
are bounded by the same pair of lines
but are opposite to each other right so
somehow growing up in Louisiana I
somehow picked up the British English
version of it maybe because the word
opposite made a lot more sense to me
than the word vertical with that said
they're the same thing Wikipedia has
shown us the light and so my logic of
opposite opposite angles is the same as
their logic of vertical angles are
congruent
next problem next problem I'll start
using the US terminology although I
think there are a good number of people
outside of the US who watt to these so
maybe it's good that I somehow picked up
the British English version of it okay
once again might be hard for you to read
I'll read it out for you two lines in a
plane always intersect in exactly one
point fair enough which of the following
best describes a counter example to the
assertion above so I like to think of
the answer even before seeing the
choices so can I think of two lines in a
plane that always interact in exactly
one point well what if they're parallel
right what if you know I have let me see
that line and that line they're never
going to intersect with each other
they're parallel that's the definition
of parallel lines the other the other
example I can think of is if they're the
same point if they're the same line I
mean I guess you might not want to call
them two lines then but you know I would
buy this line and then I had you know
another well that's parallel but matter
if they're right on top of each other
they would intersect everywhere so
either of those would be counter
examples to the idea that two lines in a
plane always exactly always intersect in
exactly one point and if we look at
their choices well okay they have the
first thing I just write they're
parallel lines
see there are two lines in a plane but
they don't intersect in one point
problem eight I'm going to make it a
little bigger from now on just you can
read it okay this is problem nine
problem nine which figure can serve as a
counter example to the conjecture below
if one pair of opposite sides of a
quadrilateral is parallel then the
quadrilateral is a parallelogram so once
again a lot of terminology and I do
remember these for my geometry days
quadrilateral means four sides right a
four-sided figure and a parallelogram
means that all the opposite sides are
parallel so for example this is a
parallelogram and if you remember or
well you know this let me see if I can
how well I can do this then like well
that's if you ignore this little part
that's hanging on there that's a
parallelogram and if all the sides were
the same it's a rhombus and all of that
but that's a parallelogram and that's
parallel because that's a parallelogram
because this side is parallel to that
side and this side is parallel to that
side all the sides are parallel now they
say if one pair of opposite sides of a
quadrilateral is parallel then the
quadrille is a parallelogram so I want
to give a counter example so let me make
one draw a figure that has two sides
that are parallel so let's say that side
and that side are parallel and then I
don't want the other two to be parallel
then it wouldn't be a parallelogram now
let's say the other sides are not
parallel so they look like let's say
they look like that and like that and
once again that you know just digging in
my head of definitions of shapes that
looks like a trapezoid to me so let's
see yeah good you have a trapezoid as a
choice trapezoid all the rest are
parallelograms right a rectangle is all
the sides are parallel and we have all
90-degree angles right rectangles are
actually a subset of parallelograms
rhombus are we have a parallelogram
where all of the sides are the same
length all the angles aren't necessarily
equal Square is all the sides are
parallel equal and all the angles are 90
degrees so all of these are subsets of
Prada gram this is not a parallelogram
although it does have two sides that are
parallel so this is the counter example
to the conjecture I think you're already
seeing the pattern a lot of geometry the
the the terminology is often the hard
part the ideas aren't as deep as a
terminology might suggest okay given
trap that all right that already makes
me worried okay given trap is an
isosceles trapezoid with diagonals RP
and ta which of the following must be
true and isosceles tribe ok let's see
what we can do here so an isosceles
trapezoid means that the two sides on
the on the the two kind of sides that
lead up from the base to the top side
are equal kind of like an isosceles
triangle so let me draw that actually
I'm kind of guessing that I haven't seen
the definition of an isosceles triangle
anytime in the recent past but an
isosceles trapezoid but it sounds right
so I'll go with it and that's a good
skill in life whoops
to make your best see so I think what
they say when they say Solly's trapezoid
they're essentially saying that this
side you know it's a trapezoid so that's
going to be equal to that and they're
saying that this side is equal to that
side so isosceles trapezoid okay which
of the following and they say RP and ta
are diagonals of it so let me draw that
so let me actually write the whole trap
so this is T are a P is a trapezoid and
let me draw the diagonals RP is that
diagonal and ta is this diagonal right
here okay
all right let's see what we can do which
of the following must be true RP is
perpendicular to TA well I can already
tell you that that's not going to be
true and you don't even have to prove it
because you can even visualize is R if
you squeeze the top part down right
imagine some device where this is kind
of the cross-section if you were to
squeeze the top down right they didn't
tell us how high then these angles you
can imagine that these at both of these
angles let me see if I could draw it
that angle and that angle which are
opposite or vertical angles which we
know you know that's the u.s. word for
it those are going to get smaller and
smaller if we squeeze it down right in
order for both of these to be
perpendicular those would have to be
90-degree angles and we already can see
that that's definitely not the case all
right our P is parallel to TA well
that's clearly not the case they
intersect
all right they're the diagonals our P is
congruent to TA
well now that looks pretty good to me
right because it's an isosceles
trapezoid you get this hole if we do a
line of symmetry here if we draw a line
of symmetry this everything you see on
this side is going to be kind of
congruent to its mirror image on that
side right so both of these lines you
can this is going to be equal to this
and I could make the argument but
basically we know that our P since this
is an isosceles trapezoid you can
imagine kind of continuing a triangle
and making an isosceles triangle here
then we would know that that angle is
equal to that angle let's see we could
make a see if that angle is equal to
that angle then well actually I'm not
going to go down that path because I
think that'll be but you can I mean you
can almost look at it from inspection
although maybe I should be it do a
little more rigorous definition of it
but RP is definitely going to be
parallel that's definitely going to be
congruent to TA right because both sides
of these trapezoids are going to be
symmetric and so there's no way you
could have RP being a different length
than TA right since this trapezoid is
perfectly symmetric since it's isosceles
and then DRP bisects TA RP bisects TA
and I think there again you can you can
show that if you were to let
say if I were to draw this trapezoid
slightly differently if it looks
something like this let me draw it like
this if this was the trapezoid and then
this is also an isosceles trapezoid and
then the diagonals would look like this
whoops the diagonals would look like
this
so here it's pretty clear that they're
not bisecting each other right it's
pretty in order from the bisect each
other this length would have to be equal
to that length and that's clear just by
looking at it that that's not the case
right that is not equal to that so
they're definitely not bisecting each
other so you can really in this problem
knock out choices a B and D and say oh
well choice C looks pretty good but you
can actually deduce that by just saying
by using an argument of all of the
angles that this angle is going to be
equal to let me see if I can make the
arc thats going to waste your time but
that's a good exercise for you is to
make the formal proof argument of why
this is true although you can make a
pretty good intuitive argument just
based on the symmetry of the triangle
itself anyway see in the next video